highway is the next chancellor of the
exchequer uh the iraqi born who arrived
in the uk as a as a kid didn't speak any
english has now risen all the way
through the ranks to become uh the
successor to rishi sunak and he's
tonight confirmed by boris johnson as
chancellor of uh the exchequer let's
just run through a couple of other
consequential posts as we've been
reporting already this evening steve
barkley who was chief of staff or went a
bit wrong under steve barkley but he's
been promoted uh to health and social
care he is the secretary of state uh uh
taking over uh from sergey javid uh and
then education secretary is the vacant
post perhaps unsurprisingly nadim
zahawi's deputy in education michelle
donalon who's regular on those morning
media rounds fighting on behalf of the
prime minister uh has been made
secretary of state for education i think
she's a victor uh for somebody uh who
stood up the prime minister time and
time and time again in the face of uh
difficult questions from journalists
about the antics uh in uh number 10. so
we were just talking about the prime
minister's dilemma do you go for liz
trust gto for nadine zaha we we now have
a choice as that ally of boris johnson
uh told john craig not that long ago
more likely to go for him brings with
him potentially a bigger slice of the
conservative party uh native zahawi of
course interesting background at one
stage he was uh a backer of dominic raab
it took him a little while to get into
boris johnson's government because he
wasn't uh he didn't put boris johnson
who he he knew well when he was mayor of
london in the early years of his uh time
as an mp but didn't back him in the 2019
leadership contest just worrying that
boris johnson was a little bit chaotic
uh worth reminding zahawi of that
tonight however he's made his way up
first as a vaccine minister
will remember that critical role he
played at that pivotal point uh on the
vaccine very competent on the media in
fact he came in after quite a lot of the
key decisions being made but shored up
the government's position on the issue
of vaccines then he was
he pivoted into education uh where he
has been for some months now uh the
reform agenda that he started to get
under the way uh get underway has
stumbled a little bit he's had to
rewrite the legislation currently in
parliament but again the priority for
boris johnson is getting a solid media
performer into uh top jobs that he
certainly wasn't the education
department and he will hope that skill
is one that transfers tonight to the
treasury and before the resignations we
saw this evening the suggestion was that
boris needed to limp forward until
recess
if this appointment works out for him
and liz trust has been offered something
to you know satisfy her and her
ambitions you know what does it buy him
time and if so how much time might it
buy him um so first thing we have to do
is as you completely rightly say watch
liz trust as foreign secretary we don't
know whether she's going to react to
that but also the question is does nadim
sahawi make different answer questions
onto the biggest questions of uh british
politics differently and we're just
looking around and seeing
a number of security guards walk past um
it's a febrile evening our eye is caught
by all sorts does nadeem zahawi tonight
begin trying to reverse some of the
biggest calls on the economy that rishi
sunak took and made rishi sunak
unpopular with parts of the conservative
party is he more willing to go for tax
cuts is he more willing to fund those
tax cuts by additional borrowing number
10 want to cut corporation tax they want
to reverse parts of the national
insurance rise they want to do all sorts
of things to lower the tax burden but as
the black door uh leaves as deputy chief
of staff simon finn walking out there
after uh what no probably signals but at
the end of the end of the most intense
bit of the reshuffle her departure
does he try to do things significantly
differently uh with an eye of pleasing
the conservative party to do what you
just suggested which is get through to
recess could we have an emergency budget
or some kind of big statement more help
now i'm old enough to remember anna when
boris johnson was saying just four weeks
ago there was no more money to help the
cost of living crisis we had to change
the rules change what's known as supply
side reform get rid of regulation to
make things cheaper the question tonight
is is more spending back on the agenda
uh because ultimately those policy
differences which risky sunac talked
about in his letter something that some
people were unhappy with his tenure and
so is it not just a change of personnel
but also a change of government
direction and is it enough